they also don't call you by your first
name they call you by your flaws yes
like fat ass but I have an uncle who was
born with like a crooked hip called them
kumia like the way he walks he's dancing
an uncle that had like a patch he had no
eye hey P
PIR and it used to go up to him be like
where's the treasure at it used to be
like what funny thing the meat shop they
called him caretto like that's just his
name like butcher or car my other Uncle
he's
devil he what was
yours
I would call me like Gava like because I
was skinny I guess or they would call me
pra cuz I'm like the darker one of my
family aunts and uncles they have to
roast you they have like a a roast
session of their kids yeah no you think
that was badong way he couldn't read
du I could have read and every like oh
my God laughing